what does Commissioner Copps sort of see
as the proper role of the FCC in
protecting consumers are policing or
having any oversight over all of those
aspects of the Internet where does he
how does he see the FCC fitting into
that broader picture well I think
Commissioner Copps would love to have
regular jurisdiction over everything but
he knows that that's uh that's not
really what the SEC is here for so I
think right now we were focusing on this
title and title to issue we are you know
when it comes to the Internet and what
rides over the internet we understand
that it's still young industry is trying
to find business models that work and we
certainly don't want to interfere with
that ultimately though the concern is
with the consumer so if when things move
along and there are issues which I don't
I can't imagine happening anytime soon
then someone will have to step in and I
guess we'll have to kind of wait and see
if it's the FCC or some other agency or
or you know